my Aunt Sally is on line two and Sal
what up just okay
you did great big thank you and Sal yeah
what was your favorite part any any good
morning squirt nation it's you up with
Nikki Glaser this is Nikki Glaser I am
in New York City because I am no longer
in Los Angeles because I was voted off
Dancing with the Stars two nights ago I
can't even believe it was just so like
two nights ago it was it was so recent
I'm in studio today in New York City Tom
Takhar is not here today he is in
Toronto all weekend performing at the
Just for Laughs festival but today to
fill in for him we've got a puddle boy
Andrew Colin bottle bottle squirt squirt
yep we're gonna come in with like a Tom
song I'm never good at the beginning or
the end in the middle though I'm great
that's what anyone remembers is the
beginning in the end and that's why
you're free huh you paid me yes I did
don't make it sound like you ever worked
I paid you well do I owe you money still
is that what this is about I mean I
didn't want to do it on air why are you
money so just fifty thousand dollars no
way no you honestly I counted it's three
walks you still I still owe you are
you serious
do I literally owe you for the box I
will venmo you right now $60 I'll send
it right back because I'm lying oh you
know what kind what kind of monster
would I be but you do owe me for
carrying that bag up the stairs like I
do I do the Andrew came over last night
and finances
how's it going in hey I I loved you on
dance ooh the Stars oh yeah it was it
was amazing and I was wondering you were
dancing so well and the judges were
terrible I thought well yeah it's like
what is your pressing question for me
well I just thought one of the judges
they had all this time to critique you
but none of them asked how's your
butthole and you know what I had so much
we clear up all Dancing with the Stars
can I just I'll just say Cheryl Burke
who's been on the show since for 21
seasons says they've never had to do
this much work on a show on the first
two weeks of a show we had to learn
three dances usually do one dance a week
in the beginning and then it gets more
intense this was I had to learn four
dances but I never got to the fourth but
I learned three never you'll see I'll
post videos from my pre her CIL's
because I do some pretty impressive
stuff in the third dance I got to say
but I got injured from working on the
third dance which I never got to perform
and then so I was just I was bummed man
I was really sad and gleb and I weren't
really getting along nothing wasn't
getting along but I was just so
disappointed myself for him because he's
such a good dancer and I want him to
like be on the show and when you're
eliminated you don't he's still gonna be
featured on the show but I was I just
felt like such a failure for him and he
was mad that I was injured but not mad
at me and we just it's such a weird
relationship with your dancer like it's
it's like a relationship and I was like
I feel like Gleb is filed for divorce
and like hasn't told me yet like that's
kind of the the sense I got like he's
already checked out and then I
eventually we did our first we kind of
connected and had a good moment before
our first dance where he was like you
got this like believe in yourself and
everything and I also got a couple
emails from people being like mind over
matter we know you're injured this one
friend wrote an email that said she
coaches gymnastics and when her gymnast
get injured she tells them to repeat the
mantra I'm strong I'm prepared and this
is easy so I just started saying I'm
strong and prepared this is easy from
the moment I was in that makeup chair
crying until Showtime I must have said
it 2,000 times out loud and
walking around people thought I was
crazy but then I went to camera blocking
an hour after makeup and I was like
about to watch the girl do my dance
again and I started kind of I watched
her video from the day before and I was
like teach me how you looked at the
camera I was asking her to do simple
things where I could actually maybe move
and get my and then I started moving and
I was like I think I can do this and
then I went out and did the camera
blocking and Tom Bergeron the host was
watching was like I thought you were
injured and I was like I did too it
literally like my mind and I am because
afterwards it mean it really hurt and
then I got but I was able to like get
through the pain by just changing my
mindset so I've always been someone
who's like oh you can meditate your way
out of pain a lot of our physical
ailments our back pain is just mental
and people always go no I actually have
a tear well I did too but it can be it
can be made worse an actual physical
tear can the pain can be made worse by
the way you mentally think about it I
know there's an injury there but you've
got to change the way you think about
your pain and your because you really
can't overcome it it still hurt because
there was an injury there but when
you're when you're going through a lot
of stress and you're down on yourself
your brain needs a place to go put that
and it finds the weakness in your body
which is wherever you have a tear and it
beats the out of it until
it you release that stress and and so
that's what I when I was able to just
like wrap my head around you're strong
you're prepared you're ready or it's
easy I yeah it was it was crazy how it
worked so I was able to dance I don't
know where I'm going with this I know
but like your actual dance like when you
were dancing did the practive to think
about it yeah practice yes that was the
problem
because I didn't have practices going in
I was not like second nature to me so
like I wasn't when I do this tonight's
show I don't have to think about what
step is next because yes it is a set
that I've constructed and I'm not used
to saying it in this order but there's
there's a cue card in front of me with
the jokes listed in case I forget which
I don't because I've said this I don't
how to do comedy but when you're doing a
step and you're like there's another set
to come the step is coming you don't get
to make a pause and go so what else am I
talking about like there's and it's loud
in there and it's like and if you don't
know this up you just don't know and you
do have
to lead you I wish I would have in
retrospect I wish I would have thought
about dancing as less of a me on my own
and gleb kind of just guiding me and it
would and that I would have looked at it
as like we were both one entity and I
think it's really hard for me as a comic
who's been it's you're so solitary I'm
there I really thought about my
performance and if you look at us I was
dancing like by myself I wasn't dancing
with him and I wish I would have thought
of it more as a unit which he tried to
get through to me so many times I I
really like love dancing now I'm gonna
do like hip hop dance classes I know
that I can learn steps I'm I wish I
would have stayed in the competition
because I would have been such a more
fast learner it took me a month to learn
to dances that were very similar and but
then the third dance I got so much
quicker I would have and then different
styles of dances I would have been so
good at the foxtrot like where it's like
you just are like bought like kind of
like it's a slower dance I would have
been so good at it I kind of got screwed
with my dance style up top I'm not like
a sexy salsa mama that's a little
intimidating we come in the box with
that's how I always thought of you yeah
it was just but let me just tell you
being eliminated from a reality show
where it's like dumb dumb and the next
to go like I was on that show I mean
I've been on that show before cuz I've
been on Last Comic Standing twice and
been eliminated where they go moving on
but I've never had my name said as the
eliminated you know what I mean like
it's usually like and moving on and then
your name doesn't get said but I've
never heard and you minutes I knew I
knew I was going I was staring down at
the ground and I knew they were gonna
say Nicki and glub I just knew it I knew
it before I had so much fun after I
danced because I just wanted to have a
good showing I wanted to have a good
talk time with the judges and with Tom
and with Aaron and yeah I wanted that
all to go well and when that was done
there was like a live performance from
this girl whose song Mackenzie Ziegler
she's she sang the song wonderful which
we have to bump in and out of break the
rest of the show with a song wonderful
it just came out I'm obsessed with it
she played it so many times in
rehearsals that I learned the song
so by the time she played it for the
first time on air see I wrote the song
so it's amazing and she's so good
that I just like danced by myself like
not by myself but like all we were all
up in this Sky box which is like the
balcony where all the dancers like the
little bullpen and we were all up there
and I just like danced during the like
during her performance and like I was
like this is my last time to like be on
the show have fun no cameras were on me
and I just had the greatest time at this
like Mackenzie Ziggler concert is how I
treated it and then I went downstairs
and got eliminated and felt I just felt
bad because I wanted Gleb to like have
his showing on TV and he will like he'll
go on and I think we'll be fine he's
gonna be fine but he really is so hot
I met him eeeh and so yeah so yesterday
so I flew to New York immediately with
Gleb and then I go you know what I'm
gonna spin this bitch tomorrow I'm going
on Good Morning America who has that
opportunity that often this is still
part of the show I'm gonna kill it on
Good Morning America so I started
writing jokes
I started strategizing with Gleb what
are we gonna talk about how are we gonna
do this segment and I was like we have
one more performance let's nail it and
we went in to Good Morning America with
one hour of sleep we both got on the
plane we watched I feel pretty together
I fell asleep he loved it and he's like
you should do more acting like he like
was like trying to push me into the
thing that I'm actually good at and and
we went on Good Morning America we
killed we had the best we had the best
morning cuz when we did whenever glove
and I dance is always a struggle because
I'm so bad at it and he gets frustrated
and eventually we have fun and we had
good rehearsals but whenever we would go
do press together it was so much fun
because I got to shine and show what I'm
good at
and I got to teach him a thing or two
because he wants to be better about
being on mic on the mic because he's you
know English is his second language and
he's he's like so hot that he like
doesn't have to like talk for people
don't want him like him Kevin Hart's
gonna be in here in a second should we
talk to him about having resentment yes
oh look at he's getting all ready to
come in here I'm sure he still hates a
lot of people yeah he's about to hate
one more don't open with the teeth
walking in the studio now Kevin Hartz
[Music]
they're anticipating that you'll see
something in them and produce something
[Laughter]
yeah get out of here I'm from Wilmington
Delaware I Drive up to Philly every
night were you in the mr. ride moaning
years are important mr. Ross okay what
does that mean make sure he in line
number two candidate you just came into
a conversation we were talking about
holding onto resentments people in the
business early on who tried to like hold
you back as the comedian I had a female
comic who just hated me and spread lies
about me and rumors to hold me back and
letting go of those eventually and I
just talked myself through it and
realize I'm still very what about you I
am a I'm a different breed I don't I
don't let uh I don't let much bother
it's hard to it's hard to poke a hole in
my armor yeah reason why is because this
is my this is gonna help you a lot it
takes so much energy to be negative you
waste so much energy holding a grudge or
figuring out ways to maintain anger you
got to create it every day or every time
you see that person you gotta conjure up
more anger I was happy but now let me be
mad
and that energy is energy that's being
misused you know so if you're true to
your craft if you're true to what you
really do that's energy that should be
placed and put into what you love if you
choose not to do that then ultimately
you're cheating yourself so when I
understood at a young age and I got tons
of rejection is that this is what's
supposed to happen I'm supposed to go
through this because ultimately it's
gonna stop and when it stops I'm
supposed to be okay and ready for
whatever opportunities that are coming
my way
so instead of looking down on a hate or
the negativity or the nose I embraced it
I love that and as I was voted off of
Dancing with the Stars two nights ago I
was the first contestant eliminated big
story is walking up to go on voted off
Dancing with the Stars
a lot of resentment towards that's the
last thing where you've agreed to it and
it's been something that is what's been
the scariest endeavor you've taken on
professionally I guess Gary's endeavor
where are you
you've had the most fear cuz I I've
never danced before in my life and I was
like I'm about to do something I'm I
know I'm terrible on on national
television have you ever have you done
something like that and and how did you
feel on the other side of it tons just
tons yeah then tons of things what's
this most the most nervous you've been
are the most like oh do I have this
but mostly nervous it's gonna sound
crazy but I'm probably the most
confident person in the world so even
when I've been like holy cow no yes no
way I still would put on the face like
I'm okay like I did fool's gold because
a movie called fool's gold that we had
to film in Australia and I lie there
like oh you okay with water or you can't
get in the water
yes like I'm actually an excellent
swimmer you know like this is true story
yeah Junior Olympics yes excellent what
was your stroke a hundred meter
backstroke 50-meter freestyle nice my
prime and for a minute one between my
ages of like 12 and 15 I was in
hundred-meter I am that's when I was
like really really moving I was ro deal
yeah I'm like a 20 20 point to 50-meter
freestyle yards hundred meter backstroke
guys probably like the 53:54 range I'm
pretty good I don't like unless unless I
know like where I am in the ocean and
what is in here and I've heard it
specifically I don't like the ocean
Australia is a different ballgame when
it comes to the ocean cuz everything is
there everything is it all straight
white sharks so man this scene came up
and they like art is where you fall in
the water and I was like hi it was like
these air Ganges that we kept hearing
about was like the most deadliest
jellyfish in the world but we had heard
rumors that they were in the water man I
said guys I don't know what do you mean
you don't know that I just don't I just
don't know I feel like it's Erik Angie
but you said you were okay with the with
the ocean I think no I definitely said
that I definitely said that because like
well you got to get in and I was like I
just want to talk to y'all about it I
just don't I don't know if we need this
moment do we and instantly I I said okay
let's do it and I did about 13 of the
worst takes that you've ever seen and
you're like let's get edited out the
movie it was so bad but I knew it like
as I'm doing now this is this is gonna
see the light of day I'm not even this
is complete fear how it's supposed to be
the tough guy in this situation I'm not
pulling it off at all I was the most
uncomfortable I've ever been but
afterwards I was like that is with this
show drugged II can't change it you
can't change it I saw I know on to the
next thing was that in your back pocket
yeah I mean but what is the because
getting voted off a reality show the on
the being the first one voted off like I
lost like I lost the most it's got to be
some
somebody what what's the most rejection
what do you do when you feel that that's
that level of rejection which is like
this is the worse I could do and it
happened my biggest fear happened which
I mean what level of experience every
level of rejection has it ever has it
ever got you down in a way where you
really had to overcome it are you two
good ones yeah
comic strip Lucien Lucien I was lasting
holes was it hold sir hold I was around
for that but yeah Lucien legend for
picking talent yeah cuz the man had
discovered Eddie Murphy
Lucien Kevin you got an audition at the
comic strip oh my god I've been killing
all around town I got in every comedy
club comic strip was last they saved the
best for last
I'm going here and I'm a kill I'd go
perform crowd goes crazy I can admit
that my jokes back then worked at a
groundbreaking this wasn't a
cutting-edge material but it was good it
was good enough yeah
I'm a young comic I'm 24 after you get
off stage Lucien called you in the back
room and he sit you down saying finally
a few pass um I've never been more
confident in my life this is it hey
Lucien had a disease and I remember you
know his hands and stuff were taped up I
forgot what the disease words but like
things were fall off like MEMS were
falling off this is making jokes 'yes
yes like it was this was real right you
know so yeah bandages and stuff for him
but it didn't matter like this guy's a
legend yeah in his most vulnerable state
you know the last stages of the disease
he was dealing with this man told me he
said comedy isn't for you you know
waiting for them waiting for the hood he
said maybe you should pursue something
else maybe you find a job but I've
comment I don't see swimming I don't see
in SOCOM I just don't see
you doing this long what what are you
talk what do you I don't understand he
just kill I just killed he's like that's
not just I just don't see talent edges
I'm not gonna pass you oh and I sat
there for a second and I remember his
hands were like his hands like up in the
air I could said mean things I could
have been like you you know I could have
said a lot of stuff I stared at him for
a minute
I'm like thank you like within this
condition uh-huh thank you that's it yes
that's it I get up I walk out my front
Keith Robinson is outside he's like wait
what'd he say stupid thing yeah you told
me I should get a regular job for me
this is not a good job like I should
find something else and Keith's honest
reaction he was like him him
so what stupid let's get some meat and
Keith is this is my mentor this is like
the guy who's been giving me advice or
whatever it didn't blink to us yeah he
wasn't devastated at all
and he said let's get some meat and it
was like nothing happened and instantly
I processed that moment as like what am
i what is that am I gonna stop because
of that information so what am i holding
on to right I immediately let it go and
we hate I was fine we went up at a spot
later that day and I just went to the
comedy clubs that accepted me and work
those and the comic strip eventually
found out I'm gonna call me later on but
I'd learn at the young age of 23 24 to
say it mmm so many people can't say
it so many people allow emotion to
overtake reality it is reality what
just happened 30 seconds ago I cannot
change I don't have that power I don't
know how to go back in time you'll
figure it out if anyone can figure out
the power
you know wave my hands and take that
time back it happened that's why I
address things the way to that do that's
why I have no problem with admitting
right from wrong I have no problem with
being real and authentic I'm a person
are you an apologizer are you is that it
come easy to you apologize are like if
you if you if you if you're wrong you
know they say never apologize for a
joker
are you good are you good at being able
to be like you know even in interactions
with your kids or your wife just saying
I'm sorry are you good apologize I guess
some people struggle with that the older
you get the more mature you get that
that should happen if it's not happening
then I suggest you sit yourself down and
ask yourself why he's supposed to get
more ministry yeah I've up a lot
I've done a lot of wrong in me doing
wrong I realize it's not just wrong it's
stupid okay Kevin how do you grow from
stupid how do you how do you grow you
embrace what you did you own it because
you made that bed so you lay in it after
you lay in it you get out that bed and
you say you know I don't want to make
this beer to get for a long time yes I
don't want to make it again so I'm now
aware I'm conscious so when you say
jokes or apologize for things you say on
stage I don't say things that are gonna
put me in a position to have to
apologize because I'm aware so the
lesson taught to myself
be aware don't be ignorant to what can
because you can always prevent it before
it happens so before you put yourself in
a position to apologize there's a beat
when you get to make a decision do I
want to do I want to
yes I want to say this do I want to call
them this name do I want to use this
term at this moment is there another
route that I can take to get the same
message across there always is do you
still make those mistakes though and are
you still willing to make those mistakes
because I am I hear what you're saying
but I when I mess up it's sometimes hard
to acknowledge it and apologize because
then I feel like an essentially flawed
person but what you're saying is like
you can acknowledge that and say no I'm
gonna be better what's wrong with being
Flo that's that's a great point what's
wrong with being flawed so
if you want to want to live a perfect
life and I hate that I'm coming off like
such a motivational speaker but I'm just
saying I know so many people want
to live a perfect life but you have no
idea what perfection is unless you've
experienced imperfection you don't know
what perfect is unless you've
experienced imperfection in other words
embrace your flaws embrace your father's
they help make you ultimately become the
perfect person you want to be yeah what
what individual do you believe that's
perfect sometimes you look and you go
they do they are perfect but it's all
just I don't really know what's going on
with them you know what what does it
matter so if you're saying I don't want
to be flawed why that's my question to
you cuz I don't want to hurt other
people I don't want to be I don't want
to be misinterpreted and thought of as a
bad person like I think there's a
fundamental part of a lot of us that
just thinks like I'm secretly I'm a bad
person people are gonna find out no I
think what I think you think too much
yeah did you do that I think you
overthink of thought before it becomes a
real thought you're thinking about the
thought behind the thought that maybe
because I think that this could it's a
bunch of that makes no sense like
you waste a time you have no action yet
yeah you're thinking about all this
stuff before an action is even taking
place Kevin Hart is here he is a new
movie out night school which I haven't
had a chance to see it Ian you saw it
you loved it some funny parts in here
man yes Tiffany Haddish Kevin Hart what
more could you ask for and this is a
movie about second chances that's crazy
that it's honestly right on par with
this conversation
well Tommy how so so back to the point
of you know what we were discussing it's
it's a movie about people that feel like
because they didn't get it right the
first time
that there's no reason to go back and
try again because they don't want to be
perceived as a person that failed I
don't look like I failed I won't look
stupid I don't want to look like I
couldn't do it something just cannot do
it we're trying to lie to make it seem
like you're not you're trying to you're
trying to create a false presentation of
who you are based on what you think the
opinions of others will be
so in this movie it basically shines a
light on those type of individuals by
looking through a lens of the character
that I played named Teddy Walker who's
putting on a facade to a woman that he's
very much in love with and making it
seem like he's in a position that he's
not
and when his charm and wit and
personality runs out and he's in a
situation where he's his back is wall
he's forced to get his GED he doesn't
have a GED but nobody knows he has to
for the first time apply himself like
he's never had while trying to hide it
ultimately he comes across other people
like himself and they band together and
realize it's okay to be who we are
yeah and the piece of paper that we look
at that can be considered the Diploma
has a much bigger meaning that piece of
paper makes you feel like hey I'm making
steps in the right direction to succeed
in life this makes me feel like I can
that piece of paper at the older age
that he was it put him in a position to
feel like he now can so this movie is
about doing things that you think you've
already it's too late to do them but
putting on an effort to do that and by
doing that by putting in the effort
maybe if you don't even get the piece of
paper it still the effort it's still
number back it's just saying like this
there's nothing wrong with failing
there's nothing wrong with later in life
- Kevin Hart though you think Kevin Hart
in you go this guy doesn't fail it's so
nice to hear that from you because the
reason you seem like someone who doesn't
fail is because you've failed so much
and you have the attitude of someone
that's that there's nothing wrong with
that that failure isn't fail it's not
failure it grooms you for the wins
right now I'm so determined to do so
much because I know what the other side
looks like now I know I can't lose
because I have so much information on
how to lose yes so I didn't take those
losses that I don't know how to properly
the winds and some people take the
losses and they just stop that yeah
there's an analogy my friend scooter
scooter braun very very good dude
Scooter Braun told me something one day
and it stuck with me he said if I were
to tell you that right now I'm giving
out five million dollars to the first
average individual that can hit a home
run with a pitch thrown by a major
league pitcher he said there's gonna be
a line that that probably is the length
of the entire city there's gonna be a
line crazy people lined up the way in
that line could be days before you get
to get up to bat he said so many people
want to get in that line they're gonna
strike out cuz it's a major league
pitcher and when they strike out they
have the opportunity to go back to the
end of that line and wait again if they
want to or not or they can go I have no
way I'm gonna hit this pitch scooter
said the difference between me and
everybody else in the world I'm gonna
keep getting back in that line until
they stop doing whatever it is they're
doing Wow
he said I'm gonna get back in that line
and wait
he said because that line is gonna get
shorter and shorter because nobody else
is gonna want to wait when he said that
I immediately said to myself I would be
getting back in the line because that's
the type of person I am
mmm-hmm so with that analogy it's a
great moment for you to ask yourself who
are you do you wait in line for three
days to take three swings at a ball
that's being thrown at 105 miles per
hour or do you get up there for the
first time ago or there's no way I mean
that it could all be based upon how
many people quit and then the last three
people they could get lives thrown at
him yeah because they want to give the
money way you would never know because
you turned your back away before you got
to that point I'd be the person that
paid
someone to wait in line for me this
conversation with you feeling better
about just everything you're so
inspirational you're so you're so
incredible I can't wait to see night
school you gotta check out my mom I
thought went to night school for years I
was like my mom went to night school
because we'd always drop her off at
night school
turns out she got a DUI school right
she's like no I did it and I go I
remember dropping you off there DUI
thank you so much for being here thank
you for your wisdom and God I just love
you so much see night school it is in
theaters everywhere let's make this a
huge box-office hit Tiffany Haddish I
have an art what it's I can't wait
night school is the movie Kevin Hart
thank you so much thank you he's a he's
a good gym dropping foot before I go
dance with the Stars was dope simply
because you got a platform to show that
I'm okay with not being comfortable yes
and now that you did that now you're
back to being comfortable move on all
right we'll see you guys next week on
the show thanks for hanging out with us
this week squirt squirt
[Music]
you